the sound you just heard was the entire
Disney Plus launch team smacking
themselves in the heads while projecting
a collective dough into the stratosphere
you probably already heard that the
hotly anticipated streaming service made
its debut bringing with it all manner of
titles from the Disney Vault
not to mention a slew of properties of
the Star Wars Marvel and Pixar
persuasion we're pretty sure you also
heard that launch day for Disney Plus
was far from perfect with many early
subscribers unable to even log on to the
service those that were finally able to
log on and had a hankering for some
early episodes of The Simpsons were met
with their own set of issues when they
found that those episodes of the beloved
animated series appeared to be missing
something significant portions of the
picture
the problem it seems stemmed from
Disney's decision to screen all content
on Disney Plus in the widescreen aspect
ratio of sixteen by nine on the surface
that seems like a sound choice by the
house of mouse as the widescreen ratio
is by far the most popular for home
viewing computer monitors and
flat-screen televisions display images
rendered in this aspect ratio' natively
and it's standard for HDTV broadcasts
and digital media the problem lies in
the fact that The Simpsons has been on
the air since before the format was in
wide use before in fact consumer
flat-screen televisions even existed and
that earlier episodes were aired in the
den standard four by three aspect ratio
episodes of the series were produced in
the sixteen by nine format until its
20th season and when the four by three
aspect ratio is cropped for the newer
formats a large portion of the picture
is lost so much to the dismay of the
show's fiercely loyal and often
fanatically astute fan base the first 19
seasons of The Simpsons are indeed only
partially streaming on Disney Plus
[Music]
panicking now for some shows that would
not be a significant problem but as any
Simpsons fan would be quick to tell you
part of what's made the show so special
is that some of its best jokes are not
front and center rather the creative
teams behind The Simpsons have long
reveled in the chance to hide sly in
jokes and savage social jabs in
virtually every corner of the frame
that's obviously a big part of what has
made the Simpsons one of the more
endlessly rewatchable shows in the
history of television it's also exactly
my fans were so excited at the chance to
revisit some of their favorite early
moments of the iconic series on launch
day but for now at least it seems that
those brilliantly winking comedic
morsels have been unceremoniously nixed
as Disney made the questionable decision
not to adjust the aspect ratio for Homer
and the rest of the Simpson family's
game changing early episodes rest
assured that I was on the internet
within minutes registering my disgust
throughout the world the decision to go
ahead and screen the cropped versions of
those early episodes is even more
surprising because it seems that there's
no way that the house of mouse wouldn't
have known this would be an issue
after all extended cable outlet FXX now
owned by the Walt Disney Company
did the exact same thing when it began
airing episodes of The Simpsons back in
2014 and it also experienced the same
sort of backlash from the series's
eagle-eyed fandom it seems like it'd be
pretty simple for Disney Plus the remedy
the issue by offering earlier seasons in
4x3 or perhaps even giving viewers a
choice between the two aspect ratios but
so far Disney hasn't announced any plans
to do anything of the sort and in fact
the entertainment megalith has been mom
on the whole uproar while we wait to see
how Disney Plus addresses it's launched
a Simpsons crisis it seems that most of
the show's fans are at least trying to
take the issue in stride if only because
they're beyond excited to stream all 30
seasons of the series still there is a
faction of fans already threatening to
cancel their Disney Plus subscriptions
if the problem is not addressed for the
time being it seems like they'll just
have to make do with watching some of
the series as best episodes without
getting all of the in joking goodness
they're used to maybe in the future
we'll all forget this ever happened
smithee's use the initially I mean the
revolver sir precisely be sure to wipe
your own memory clean when you've
finished check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]